hi I'm Jen and I'm Nikki and today we're
talking about the untold stories of
queer people throughout history because
they existed and they were very cool so
cool so fun Oh sexy outing people is not
cool but these stories already exist
these people are long gone and we're not
making anyone's life worse in fact we
were probably making it better it's
making my I better that's for sure when
that's where they're edgy today we are
talking about none other than Latina
icon Frida Kahlo widely regarded as a
feminist icon prized artists whose image
is unmistakable we're gonna look into
the queer relationships in her lights
that she may have had with other women
we're actually also notable women we're
talking just about tiny portion of her
life today I can't always Frida was born
on July 6 1907 in Oaxaca in Mexico for
most of her life she struggled with many
physical ailments that some suspect
caused her to associate pain with love
and care also gets worked into her art
later in her life though she is known
now for her Mexican dresses and shawls
on occasion she would crush dress and
wear trousers and a shirt to work which
you know it's not we're wearing shirts
to work also tropical Thank You Sadie is
later in life she would like cut her
hair really short in her art she would
paint herself in men's suits while also
wearing earrings and heels very fluid
gender presentation which again for the
time crazy that somebody would be so
open about experimenting with gender
especially that long ago is really brave
and also yeah so brave really cool
especially in a very conservative like
very Catholic culture in Mexico as well
when she was 15 she met her future
husband Diego Rivera who was painting a
mural at her school and she kind of like
marched up to him and was like you're
gonna teach me because I like what you
do he was 20 years older than her okay
and then they got married in 1929
so she was math she was 20 to 22 very
tumultuous relationship
they both had multiple affairs
okay they separated got divorced and
then remarried Diego also slept with
Freitas sister okay yeah very
complicated relationship we are going to
focus on her queer relationships this so
Diego is noted and important throughout
her life but we're alright is rumored
that Frida had affairs with
american-born French entertainer
Josephine Baker nice Mexican folk singer
Avila Vargas nice yes American artist
Georgia O'Keeffe names here I just like
love hot women being caught together all
hot women hot Josephine Baker okay
according to a biography about Josephine
the two of them met following a
performance at Josephine's nightclub
okay who maybe like a romantic setting
the two of them did come out as bi to
each other that's beautiful man later
became lovers God that's about all that
we know personally about they were like
who we're like young hot women artists
you're by I'm bi cool that is cool
Tamela Vargas was born in Costa Rica and
immigrated to Mexico as a teenager she
was a singer fun fact about her she
would sing Mexican folk songs originally
and predominantly performed by men I
would sing around chero music without
changing the pronouns well granted songs
about women that's incredible
also she would wear men's clothing drink
and smoke heavily and carried a pistol
also chabela vargas in her autobiography
came out as a lesbian which was anyway
confirmed gay
confirmed Chameli Vargas met Frida and
Diego huh at a party that the couple was
hosting it's rumored that Frida and
availabe then became involved in the
1940s and Trevino would
with frita for a time to know how common
that is for you just to be like hey come
on live with me and then for the other
person be like okay if you want someone
to like be there when you wake up and be
there when you go to bed it's probably
because you want to do stuff with them
in between those two things and travail
also said that she was a great love of
free does and loves by Freitas bedside
when she died and Freda once told
shillelagh I live only for you and Diego
that's really sweet
to utter that I live only for you and my
husband in the same room like are they
on the equal playing fields in her head
none of this is speculation at this
point it's just like right she was like
I loved this woman so that was Tommy
Oliver gets Laos lifelong relationship
friendship more than friendship great
love in her work next time is Georgia
okay Georgia okie American artists Wow
there's some speculation that Georgia
O'Keeffe's flowers were actually vulvas
I agree that some of her artwork could
be interpreted as genital in nature in
nature literally yeah so what about
Georgia and Rita did they kiss Sabrina
and Georgia met in New York
okay and the first time he met Freda
bragged about flirting with Georgia okay
good for you freedom according to her
friend Lucien block Frieda was quote
very irritated by the famous okie which
people are thinking is due to feelings
of competition because they're both
women in the same space and both artists
yeah to me that felt very much like wow
I'm like flirted with her issued better
than me she's not better than me I'm
better than she is but I like her but I
don't like her right like there's some
sexual tension of like wow maybe I like
that you're better than me but you're
not better than me
the two met one another on multiple
occasions correspondent a lot visited
one another often in
letter from Frieda to Georgia there's a
line that reads I thought of you a lot
and never forget your wonderful hands
and the color of your eyes
I would be so happy if you could write
me even two words I like you very much
Georgia Sean John thank you very much
Georgia that's like it's newer trying to
seducer Frieda is like laying it all
down just to be like George Raft you
even want just a little bit of this
saucy let's make it happen in an
unpublished letter from Frieda to a
friend in Detroit Frieda says O'Keefe
was in the hospital for three months she
went to Bermuda for arrest she didn't
make love to me at that time I think on
account of her weakness too bad well
that's all I can tell you until now all
right so welcome back this hospital and
she's too weak to make love to me at
that time it must have been the reason
why she didn't me it's because she was
sick of the hospital why is in the
hospital we don't know but what she
doesn't know is that they didn't smash
probably because she was too weak to to
me it sounds like they had smashed at a
right time yes like like this time we
didn't smash she's not not into me she's
just too sick to bone yeah exactly
there's a lot of stuff that we can
speculate about Frias relationships with
other women but it is nice that there is
some confirmation in the form of these
letters in the form of their
autobiographies that that there was real
love and even some real sex going on
smashy smashy I feel like just like
revolutionary people in the history of
the world who surprised if they're a
little bit queer yeah let us know in the
comments if there's anyone in history
that you would like to talk about
explore or do a little bit of
recreations what up creations yeah if
there's nothing out there you think was
a little maze hope it will get to it
[Music]